hi good evening everyone um really
thrilled to be here with shira and
cecilia who's work i've been reading uh
on facebook uh and beyond for a long
time in fact shira i first remember
reading your work uh
when you were middle east correspondent
for the for the times of london which is
whose offices i i'm currently sitting in
um so yeah versatility is clearly part
of your journalistic armory
and you've worked for buzzfeed for npr
as a foreign correspondent and are now
cyber security reporter for the new york
times so
interesting career fascinating career
frankly um
and cecilia your national technology
correspondent for the new york times i
remember first reading you at the
washington post um so you're kind of a
master of
washington and where where policy and
politics meet uh with technology and and
that is obviously a pretty hot space and
has been for quite a while now
um
and you know you both have written
separately together for the new york
times about
technology and in particular facebook uh
this kind of behemoth that
affects all of our lives in one way or
another even if you're not on it even if
you're not on instagram even if you're
not on whatsapp um it affects your life
uh almost every day i think it's fair to
say and so you've written this book um
an ugly truth inside facebook's battle
for domination
i've read it it's great and it's
probably i think my colleague hugo
rifkin in the times yesterday called it
probably the best
kind of
history of facebook we've had so far
um it's obviously it's still quite a new
company it still changes almost week to
week but um it's pretty comprehensive
certainly in recent years uh but also it
takes us back to some of those
uh founding relationships and why how
important they are and how they sit at
the center of facebook particularly mark
zuckerberg and joel sandberg as
dynamics between them so we'll get into
all of that um
i guess you know
to start with um i'd be really
interested to know from you both uh
why you how and why you chose to
write this book how how you came to sort
of take because i'm always very jealous
i don't understand how journalists find
time to write books because i barely
find time to write articles so
how did you
how did this project start and and why
really
i think it really started out of a
natural partnership between cecilia and
myself we had written so many articles
together
in which we found ourselves repeating
things over and over facebook apologizes
facebook admits mistakes were made um
facebook says it's going to change and
you know there's a pattern there and as
a reporter you always have so much left
over in your notebook so much sort of
juicy colorful behind-the-scenes details
of how these conversations happened who
was involved that add nuance and
perspective to incredibly consequential
moments uh both here in the united
states and really globally and so being
able to take all that and put it in a
book and not just say well facebook made
a mistake with cambridge analytica or
facebook made a mistake when it came to
russian election interference but to
take you into the rooms with those
mistakes happened and where decisions
were made about how facebook was going
to handle it it just it felt worthy of a
book and it felt like a story that we
could really we could really tell well
together with you know cecilia and her
expertise in washington and myself out
in uh in san francisco
yeah
i would only add that this actually
started with one question that our
editor at the new york times asked us
back in 2017 i think which was when some
of the first scandals were coming to
light about foreign election
interference
and privacy problems um she asked her
name is plee wingtan she asked what
really is going on at facebook and that
was an important animating question
because so much have been written about
facebook and facebook is so
incredibly concerned about controlling
its image it has hundreds of public
relations people to make sure to to
protect their image
we thought it was actually just for us
journalistically we were incredibly
curious to try to really dig into that
question and to go beyond the talking
points beyond the varnish image that
facebook presents to understand really a
few things how the company works as a
technology how the company works as a
business model who the leaders are and
what kind of decisions they're making
and
i will not pretend that we came up with
this plan from the very beginning it was
quite a journey josh as you said like
you don't know how people write this
book i'm not necessarily one to
recommend writing a book it was hard but
it's been very rewarding at this point
um and that's what we tried to cover in
the book it's sort of those three
aspects the leadership the business and
the technology
and that's just before we get into the
meat of it i think that's really
interesting you mentioned facebook's
public relations because you know i
wrote
a profile recently of nick clegg
obviously a senior figure on facebook
for our magazine at the sunday times and
you know i've dealt with a lot of public
relations officials in my life some
better than others uh some more active
than others i have never come across
anything
like the facebook public relations
machine
i felt like i knew these people better
than any of my own family by the time
i'd been you know this was one piece in
a you know in a magazine not even in
america about one facebook figure
how hard has it been for you guys to
navigate
that i mean you know are they scared of
you are you scared of them what is this
relationship like and how much of your
time do you spend
fending off
facebook's just enormous and enormously
skillful public relations you know i was
dealing with guys who were you know ex
you know top advisors to top most
democratic politicians it seemed um
you know how does it work for you
um you know josh you mentioned that i i
spent a decade in the middle east much
of that writing for the times of london
um i uh i'm very practiced at dealing
with dictatorships um with authoritarian
regimes that don't want stories told i
think that's probably what attracted me
to writing about a lot of these really
big tech companies that have so
controlled their message i mean many of
us become journalists because
we want to get accurate and truthful and
objective information out there we don't
want the varnished company
you know pr line that's that's not what
um that's not what serves democracy it's
not what serves the public um
and i i i can't say how uh if facebook
is scared of us i i can say that we are
not afraid of facebook um
we found in the journey of reporting
this book
that
employees wanting to talk to someone
facebook is somehow sometimes taking the
line that we only spoke to employees
that were disgruntled and i would i
would say that's absolutely not the case
you know the 400 some people we spoke to
for the book the vast majority still
work at the company they spoke to us
because they they care about facebook
they saw things going off the rails they
saw their leadership making mistake
after mistake and not accounting for it
and their motivation wasn't wasn't
making the company better it was
enforcing their executives really to be
transparent about what happened there
and and perhaps you know start change
um and so yes i mean we're incredibly
thankful to the people that spoke to us
for this book because it made it
possible to not have to deal with you
know as you know 10 hour long pr phone
calls that go on over the course of a
week
and speak to people who weren't reading
off a script
um
so you know look the the narrative of
facebook to put it crudely has been sort
of hero to zero
in the sense that you know we
you know i first started using facebook
in 2006 i just joined university
it was really fun and we had a lot of
fun with it
i'm sure we all made stupid mistakes at
the time but it was great and we were
all kind of besotted with this new
technology it was connecting us to each
other i made friends you know traveling
in australia and i kept in touch with
them and you know it was it was a lot of
fun
by 2017 2018
um you know facebook's
reputation really was in the gutter and
you know we now have this books by
people y'all you'll know well people
like shoshanna zubov roger mcnamee um
you know really and others really
painting facebook as
a possibly the most significant threat
to our democracy today that it's
undermining our elections that it's
undermining the way we
act as a society that's allowing hate to
flourish that it's allowing burmese
hunters to
you know uh
to to oppress their populations that
it's been the tool of authoritarian
government how bad is facebook now i
know there's a big question but you know
we've maybe swung too far the other way
do you think the pendulum has become
uh
you know too unfair to facebook or
actually are these problems just as
profound as its critics say they are
well look
facebook has 3.4 billion users across
these three apps around the world
it is the historically the largest
communications
communications tool to ever connect that
many people on earth
it is big is powerful it deserves
attention and it deserves scrutiny
absolutely
it is um it is a company as far as how
how bad is it well it's i think some of
the anecdotes can let people judge for
themselves i mean even today very
recently
the chief of staff of the white house
said that when
they're talking to americans who aren't
willing to be vaccinated he they ask
these americans well why not and
oftentimes the people will say things
that are just false like the vaccine
leads to x y and z which is completely
ludicrous and false and then the white
house asks well
how did you get that information and
almost always this is wrong claim the
chief of staff the white house said they
learned it on facebook so we're still
seeing the the present danger of the
flow of misinformation we're seeing the
present danger of of a business model
that prioritizes engagement in growth
and therefore
doesn't put the safeguards in place and
a company doesn't have a lot of the
speech policies in place to protect its
users so
i can't say how dangerous it is i think
a lot of people already have their own
opinions and there is a lot of great
literature out there already i think
what we do in the book is
really lift the hood for people to
understand how this actually works and
through example of an example example
show in in real like very colorful
detail
what the consequences are of this
and shara
yeah i mean i think that you mentioned
myanmar for me that was like really
honestly one of the most powerful
chapters in the book to write because
it's a story that people think they know
um i think people understand that
facebook played a role in spreading hate
speech there but i don't think people
understand how many warnings facebook
got i mean we document in detail in this
book how people were raising flag after
flag after flag and saying this is this
is bad you know it's not it's not just
one post it's not just a dozen posts it
is radicalizing people um in in
anti-muslim hatred across myanmar and to
see facebook ignore that even when
someone comes to their company
oh gotta stall out oh sheriff rice i'm
gonna you know we have become like a
mind melt sharing myself so i might even
be able to complete her thoughts yeah i
bet you moderate right now over 100
languages are so good
i'm sorry i didn't realize that you lost
me i don't know when you lost me
um somewhere in uh sort of yeah me and
mom somewhere in my i'm lost in myanmar
um
in the patterns there and they had you
know one burmese speaking moderator in a
country where over 100 languages are
spoken to me that was such a damning
detail um
you know how can you possibly hope to
understand what's happening in myanmar
how can you possibly hope to avert the
spread of hate speech there when you
don't even have people that are speaking
the languages to moderate the content
that is coming from there
so
doesn't there's a there's a kind of
vignette at the beginning or more than a
video sort of a a a chapter if you like
at the beginning of your
book that is very eye-catching to me and
it's about facebook engineers
uh
who were fired about seven years ago 52
of them
um for
abusing the system and in this case it
was
using it to stalk women or to
um you know find out what women were who
they wanted to date or to check up on
women who had rejected them this sort of
thing
um
and
the reaction from facebook obviously
these people do eventually get fired but
it's it's that classic facebook
thing we've seen that it's it's kind of
slow
it's it it doesn't quite seem to worry
it doesn't quite seem to give the
problem the precedence it probably
should have done well i wonder why you
started the book with that
story and what it sort of illustrated
for you about the company that you were
writing about
um
you know we thought it showed something
about what their priorities were so in
order to understand the importance of
that anecdote you have to understand why
these engineers were able to stop women
essentially and and find that kind of
data on users and it's because for mark
zuckerberg when he launched the company
when he hired his first employees the
priority was growing as quickly as
possible it was moving fast and scaling
things we have a profanity in the book
which i'm not going to include on on the
show today but engineers were encouraged
to ship products as quickly as they made
them and in order to do that he gave
them free access to user data it was a
way of getting them to work very quickly
you don't have to theoretically see if
something works you can test it on a
real person in that moment and see do
they like this feature that i've created
or not
even though they were firing people year
after year and those those 52 people you
mentioned that was just in one i think
two year time frame that was studied we
don't know how many people were fired
before then and we don't know how many
people were not caught we just know that
in one two year time frame they caught
52 people
they kept that feature going until it
was literally flagged them in a report
they could no longer ignore their new
head of security said this is a huge
issue your own employees are over and
over again abusing their access to user
data because you have not created
ways and systems to catch them and stop
them you have you have made it so that
you know it's a matter of time before
this happens again and he insisted that
it that it be changed it was only then
that mark zuckerberg sort of said oh
right well let's change this
it highlighted for us a problem and a
pattern that was going to repeat over
and over again in every chapter which is
not acting proactively not seeing around
the next corner and honestly not not
seeing the potential for for for you
know for things being misused and things
being misused by bad actors
and so you know at the at the very core
of facebook and and at the core of your
book is
this relationship between mark
zuckerberg and sheryl sandberg
um
and
they also got on quite an interesting
journey
there's an interesting narrative to arc
to that it starts it's this kind of
magic meeting at a party
they talk for hours you get the senate
zuckerberg
isn't that interested in most people
don't really think most people have much
to say to him because he's so ahead of
everyone but he really wants to listen
to sheryl sandberg he senses that she
can provide something for facebook but
he doesn't have he has this vision he
has these skills but he doesn't
necessarily have the business now the
washington clout to turn it into what it
is today so they have this kind of
meeting
and for a long time it seems like a kind
of golden partnership
but in your book you show that it has
soured somewhat in recent years possibly
over the trump era which you know soured
so many relationships and broke so many
friendships and um
so talk me through their partnership and
where are they today i mean
one can conclude somewhat from your book
that sherlock is not the power she once
was at facebook but tell me more about
them
yeah
you know as one executive
told us and it's in the book um
the company is no longer led by a number
one and a number two is now led by
number one in many so that tells you the
current state of facebook
so what happened when facebook began to
as you said went from hero to zero when
it really was was you know going to this
sort of downward reputational spiral
is mark zuckerberg decided to seize much
more control over all the things
actually that he found boring and that
he delegated to sheryl sandberg for many
many years that meant especially policy
decisions and what was happening in
washington
and he was really upset and he expressed
to people that he was really upset with
the way that cambridge analytica the
data privacy scandal as well as election
interference had led to this this
reputational crisis for the company he
blamed sheryl sandberg it should be
noted that both of those things they're
both sort of breaches
that stem from his side of the business
he was a products guy he was making the
decision that allowed data sharing and
allowed for for these things to happen
that were that cheryl sandberg was
supposed to clean up image-wise so he
was disappointed
and we saw in what's known as the
wartime meeting around 2008 mark
zuckerberg declares to his executives
and we have in the book
a meeting where he essentially says like
look a ceo during peacetime
can do what i did before you know which
is to delegate certain things but when
you're in wartime you have to really
seize control and mark zuckerberg
is somebody who really sees himself as
you know in this case he kind of
compared to himself as like a godfather
mafia boss but he also sees himself as
like a great leader um
like uh caesar augustus he really
actually really looks to caesar augustus
as a real role model
and um and so it was a real turning
point for him personally
and we saw mark zuckerberg taking really
really much more
um control over big decisions on house
speaker nancy pelosi
videos about her that were doctored and
false about donald trump himself and
whenever he would post things that
actually violated the company's speech
policies for any other person but not
for trump
and we saw actually the consequences of
that of course but we also saw that
sheryl sandberg who was really in a way
hired not just to do the things that
mark zuckerberg didn't want to do but
was kind of hired to be the adult in the
room
that her role began to diminish so what
we're seeing right now is a partnership
that used to be much more
um
sort of a self-serving like
self-self-reinforcing kind of great
cycle of both of them bringing something
different and what the other one needs
to him taking a much bigger role and her
role actually be much more questionable
so just to remind everyone uh if you've
got any questions as we go along stick
them in the q a box and you know we'll
obviously address them later on in the
chat
um
so
you know you you say the company went
from
you know one and two to one and many uh
one of those many you know and i've
mentioned already is nick clegg someone
i'm interested i think a lot of brits
are interested in because we you know
said goodbye to nick clegg um
a few years ago and we remember him from
the coalition government here
and he's totally reinvested reinvented
himself with some success um
as a top-level figure at facebook
how important is nick clegg's
role at facebook how much how valued is
he and is he partly responsible for the
for the s
for the somewhat marginalization of
cheryl sandberg
yes i mean
he um you know he's in a way he's become
facebook's chief diplomat facebook is
currently facing some very um
challenging battles in europe and in the
rest of the world and um nick clegg's
experience in europe is certainly i
think going to be a great asset to them
and that's that's one of the reasons
they brought him on board he also seems
to really earn the trust of some some
key executives including mark zuckerberg
and and um joel kaplan
you know i i wonder if um if this all
was happening 10 years ago if the role
he's playing now wouldn't have been
played by sheryl sandberg and it we have
seen and documented in our book how he's
done media appearances and he's gotten
out in front of controversial moments at
times where certainly that would have
been cheryl sandberg a few years ago
um i think it's going to be interesting
to see how successful he is in europe
and with the challenges that lie ahead
there and is it all talk or can he
actually make a difference um in terms
of how facebook is perceived by many
by many european leaders
and you know
the the narrative around clergy and the
narrative around facebook more generally
is we're listening we're learning
um we're changing that we've appointed
someone like nick clegg who is a you
know european liberal because we
understand that this sort of silicon
valley steam train needs reigning in
um
and
you know nick clegg has championed
something called the oversight board
which is a an external body that
facebook can
refer decisions to primarily about
content moderation
most most conspicuously whether to allow
donald trump
uh back onto the platform
um
do you that do you buy that narrative do
you think that they are interested in
structural change
or do you think this is what a lot of
people in this country feel nick clegg
has been brought there to do a pr
makeover
so that facebook doesn't have to change
to fend off regulation to protect this
business model how how do you view that
narrative
so first of all great profile josh i've
read it and i wrote a profile as well on
nick click with one of my colleagues at
the times um
i think a lot of people will say that
they do not see evidence yet of
structural change that's at least at
least the the
the
the engineering from um nick lake at all
nick clay did one really important thing
early on which was he told mark
zuckerberg you need to be out there you
need to be out there in public you need
to be out there in washington meeting
with trump and other people you need to
be out there meeting with lawmakers
around the world meeting with macron and
other world leaders and just being the
face and showing that you are in not
just in control but that facebook has a
plan
that facebook wants your press so
what they talk about in these meetings
is facebook says and this is nick craig
encouraging mark zuckerberg we embrace
regulation and we think we we realize
that we are big and we are powerful and
it's just too much responsibility so
please help us guide us the way i think
a lot of people would say inside they do
say inside and outside the company that
is a bit of a cop-out first of all
because you could and you had many
opportunities to self-regulate and
actually really self-regulate and the
other thing is that facebook is such a
big and powerful company right now it
can withstand regulation in many ways
that other companies cannot
and there are arguments that actually
regulation can even help them cement
their dominance and their and their
market share because small companies
can't break in because of their cot they
have to subscribe to those kind of
regulations so
i
i think that you know the role of a
chief diplomat if you were to further
that that great metaphor analogy that
i'm sure brought up
um it's often
meeting negotiating you know presenting
new ideas structural structurally we
have not seen anything change to some
very very key things which is number one
the fact that growth continues to be the
number one goal
and that the business model which is
based on engagement and trying to get
people to come back over and over again
and we showed through story after story
about how these things were formed these
these two really main pillars of the
company and how that's not changed at
all
and so
you know the the the allegation once
here are
one has thrown at facebook a lot is that
they are profiting off hate
that part the the core to their business
model is is
basically allowing for the proliferation
of people's absolute worst instincts
um and that draws people in and it you
know allows them to profit off that
facebook vehemently deny that you know
i can't i can hardly count how many
different people at facebook have said
to me that is not our business model we
that's not how we roll that's unfair
um you know in england we've had
you may have followed uh we've had a
sort of great
eruption of news this week following our
very tragic loss in the euros final last
sunday which was that there was a
torrent of racial abuse vile stuff told
that three england players um black
england players who who miss penalties
a lot of it on facebook and a lot of you
on instagram um
and so this debate has come up again you
know are they profiting off this stuff
why are they allowing the stuff to
proliferate do you think do you think
this stuff is core to their business
model why why can't facebook simply
prevent people sending
monkey emojis to black england players
using the n-word like why is that why
can't they just stop it what's to a lot
of lay people it just seems like maybe
just make it stop you know mark
zuckerberg is so powerful this is
technology is so advanced what's going
on
i um that's a wonderful question because
that example really is a perfect one of
how the pattern keeps repeating itself
over and over again
um
you know facebook is is very as you said
very careful to say that they don't
promote hate on their platform and
that's a very clever pr skirt of what
they do which is to promote anything
emotive on their platform what rises to
the top of facebook's algorithms are
things that inspire emotions whether
that's hate or love or anger or sadness
or outrage that's what people engage
with that's what you often see first
when you log into facebook it's the
things that are that are going to drive
your engagement
and so
that's one of the reasons why we keep
seeing these things go go viral on
facebook and spread on facebook whether
here in the united states it's a
narrative that the election was stolen
that there was widespread voter fraud
both of those things false um whether in
england it's hate speech being directed
at athletes
these things you know people will see
them and they get angry at seeing them
they're not supporting the racist
epithets that were thrown at those
football players um
but in their outrage in lingering on
that post for an extra 30 seconds or
maybe even hitting the dislike button
they're still telling facebook i'm
engaged in this i've spent more time on
your platform when you showed me this at
the top of my news feed
and so
you know the talk is often of regulation
we hear it in brussels we hear it in
london we certainly hear it in
washington dc um facebook seemed pretty
good at fending off that regulation they
obviously have an incredibly
powerful and well-funded lobbying
operation people like joel kaplan and in
washington and others
um
are we ever going to see serious
regulation of facebook what what might
that look like you know
where do you think this is headed yeah i
mean
so the energy
level
toward regulation is so high it's just
so there's so much interesting interest
in regulating big tech more than i've
ever seen and i've been covering this
for quite some time
um
how specifically they can reign in the
big tech companies is really
just there's so many questions as to how
they can actually execute on that that a
federal court
recently threw out a lawsuit to break up
facebook and that shows the limits
actually of enforcement action and that
the courts in some ways think a little
bit differently than these regulators
the particularly the biden
administration's picks to to regulate
big tech the biden administration very
much has shown that it has picked people
to lead the agencies
of that oversee big tech that and these
people have been very vocal about their
desire to regulate to
better protect consumers on the internet
and to break up companies like facebook
but there's you know there is like some
limits in terms of the courts but but at
the same time i'm seeing legislative
action like i've never seen before also
a suite of anti-trust bills passed
through a house committee is going to at
some point go to the house floor and
then go to the senate
i
this is new it's a new energy that i
think um shows that there's a lot of
bipartisan interest in regulating the
companies
it's it's the question is how do you
fit
century-old decades-old in some case
centuries-old law to
to
you know to regulate companies that just
defy the definitions of the economies
and the
the businesses for when those laws were
first created it's like putting
square pegs in round holes it's really
hard right now and so
you know i
i think that they're going to be
regulated but it's not going to be even
this year it's going to be some time
and so
talk to me a little bit more about mark
zuckerberg the man i love this uh
octavian augustus uh vision he has you
know we we hear a lot about zuckerberg
the man and it's often quite quirky
stuff it's the guy who teaches himself
to butcher his own meat he's teaching
himself mandarin it's it's it's this
kind of he's portrayed to us as this
slightly
i guess cyborg like kind of you know
slightly other worldly figure
um phenomenally bright
probably not very patient with people or
you know
i don't obviously you guys he didn't
dane to be interviewed for your book um
i suspect you've you've probably both
met him over the years but
what's your sense of mark zuckerberg the
man and what does he want now i mean
he's got this trillion dollar company
the levers of world power at his
fingertips but what does he i mean he's
still
you know barely 40 or whatever he is
what is he what does he want who is he
right you know mark who you know he's um
he's 37 he's going to be 38.
um
we were really interested in that as
reporters you want to know what drives
this incredibly wealthy and powerful man
and
what was interesting was how early on in
his life
he knew that he wanted to be powerful
and historic
and that his obsession with uh you know
with augustus caesar with that time in
history with history in general and with
what creates power what creates
influence
when he launched facebook he was very
clear and we spoke to people who knew
him at that time in harvard he was very
clear that he wanted data because data
was powerful he wasn't thinking about
wealth at that point he wasn't thinking
about you know washington and u.s
politics to be honest i still you know i
don't think that's his natural state he
was thinking about data and how in this
new age of the internet the person who
held the most data about people would
therefore hold the most power
and to this day i think powers is really
what drives him and the sense that he
has achieved something in creating a
historic company that in a hundred years
history books will likely mention
facebook as the first truly global
social network
mean yeah i was as an undergraduate
thinking about how to afford better
vodka and finish my essays so that
slightly terrifies me but um
but you know there are these there's a
lovely little vignette in your book
where mark zuckerberg
hosts
uh sergey brin and larry page and eric
schmidt the three guys founders and ceo
of google um for a meeting and it's in
his
tiny little sort of studio in palo alto
and people are sitting on futons these
kind of
vast figures uh
in our technological landscape
um
and they're discussing emerging i mean
was there seriously a possibility that
google and facebook might the who might
have acquired facebook i mean it's sort
of now one amount you know one already
thinks of these companies as far too
large i mean that's a google facebook
kind of
uh
sort of aura boris i mean it's just a
terrifying thought like what what
what was that about
yeah i mean
i don't think it was a merger um and we
don't know that it was a discussion with
merger but there were discussions about
what kind of partnership could emerge um
that said
you know the mark zuckerberg at that
time when they met he was a really
really hot figure what i mean by that is
not like people were really interested
in trying to understand him there's
always a hunt for the next big founder
it's like there's just in silicon valley
this look this the the founder mythology
is so strong and the idea that there's
going to be a boy genius to create the
next technology and mark appeared to be
that person so at that point google was
a little bit more mature obviously it
started about several years before
facebook and that we everybody was
seeing the social network that was doing
something different and that there was
this guy who was very young who dropped
out of harvard he had all the same sort
of echoes of the bill gates sort of
story drop out of harvard
who was doing something that looked
impactful so yes um they all met in mark
zuckerberg's apartment um i believe that
eric schmidt sat on the mattress there
was just a kitchen kitchen table and two
chairs um
you know mark zuckerberg um as shira
said he's interested in power he's not
necessarily interested in material
things at that point clearly now we're
seeing with his many states that he does
care
about some material things for sure
and um
yes that was a time when
he turned down yahoo for a one billion
dollar merger and that was one of the
reasons why sheryl sandberg wanted to
meet him who is this guy
who was well known to turn down a one
billion dollar merger offer from yahoo
who who would have that kind of
confidence in that sort of audacity to
do so
so it was a really
interesting time for mark and you can
imagine that it fed into his confidence
and the person that he he's become today
okay we're gonna have one more question
from me and then we've got some
questions coming in at the box so if
you've got any more questions out there
now's your time to
input them um
you know july 6 obviously
a big moment for facebook the hope was
for facebook that having clearly not
come out shining from the 2016
presidential election that they were
going to have a better run this time
around they did put some new systems in
place although people like y'all
eisenstadt who's who left facebook have
said that those systems were woefully
inadequate or she wasn't allowed to
to really do what she wanted there she
was there to try and sort of improve
facebook's role in the election um
but they probably came out of 2020
better than they came out of 2016.
until maybe we got to january 6th
january 6th the invasion of the capital
what many people would call an
insurrection frankly in washington dc
um
much of which was discussed organized
activated on
surprise surprise facebook so
how
damaging was that to their kind of
narrative were getting better at this uh
we've got new safeguards
um
did january 6 just kind of send all that
up in a puff of smoke i mean what's the
aftermath of all of that been for
facebook
you know i think january 6 was an
excellent example of highlighting
exactly what facebook has not yet
addressed facebook you know
rightfully says that they have helped
stop disinformation on their platform
they've helped create a model for how
other companies can stop disinformation
by forming the security team that is now
very active
in rooting out russian iranian chinese
et cetera disinformation campaigns and
so what happened in 2016 is is now much
much harder to begin to accomplish i
mean the russian russian campaigns are
now found almost monthly on facebook and
removed
what they haven't figured out is
misinformation it's
people spreading bad information to one
another people spreading conspiracies to
one another
that's what happened on january 6th for
months this narrative spread on facebook
that the election had been stolen that
voter fraud had happened and these
groups gained traction and they got
people angry and this i mean donald
trump himself was allowed to share
things that were they were categorically
untrue about the vote and about the
election and that as that anger ferments
people unite on facebook and they
ultimately decide to come down to
washington and
you know on the eve of january 6
reporters were sending facebook examples
from groups where people were posting
assault rifles and saying i'm bringing
this gun to washington who's with me
facebook removed those groups but the
fact that reporters had to like myself
had to point them out and say to them
are you going to take this down before
they could take them down
i think it just shows how much work the
company still has to do you know it's
still a whack-a-mole approach
where they've got this hammer and
they're swiping in every direction
that you know ultimately how long can
can that be facebook's approach
yeah i mean when you're looking at
america today uh you have a third a
third of the country kind of not taking
the covered vaccines which are widely
available um and then you have a you
know a delta variant spreading rapidly
really in only in the places where
people aren't taking the vaccine and you
can't just blame all of that on facebook
of course but
it's clearly not helping um
last quick thing from me before we go on
to the q a
donald you meant which i really want to
know whether you think we will ever see
donald trump back on facebook i thought
they really rather fudged this decision
you know the oversight was going to do
it and then
yeah they kind of said actually you know
kick it the can kind of got kicked down
the road ultimately it seemed to me like
mark zuckerberg and a couple of others
were making the decision but are we ever
going to see trump back on facebook what
you know what what's the score there
well isn't it interesting that the
two-year ban ends right now trump is
banned for two years and that ban will
end in january
exactly
at a time when he can begin to run for
the president again for the 2024
election
so
i mean i don't know josh should we take
a bet right now like i don't know
i actually think he's gonna be i think
he's going to be brought back on
what about you sarah
you know i think this was going to watch
and see what he does over the next 10
for the next two years sorry um
maybe it'll depend on how likely he is
to become president again i think he's
likely to run for re-election and win
facebook might be wary of um
antagonizing uh a future president
of the united states um i do i do think
they're watching to see what he does in
the interim right now and how he uses
his platform on other he still has a
platform on other um you know more
friends social media sites and so i'm
sure they're watching that closely and
and a lot can change the next two years
yeah and i just would i i said rather
get liberally like i think either he's
gonna be put on and i the reason why i
say that is actually
because i just don't think facebook
wants to ban any political figures
really they air so strongly on free
expression they are so strongly on this
belief that political speech deserves a
special category and that bad speech
drowns out good speech and i think
that's sort of this
premise and belief and underlying
bedrock for all of mark zuckerberg's
decision is that free expression works
somehow and he believes that the site
though he's tweaked that and he's
evolved a little bit i think he's really
loath to ban any political figures
okay so we're going to turn some of our
questions
um this is an interesting one from sarah
who says what is the end goal of
facebook does mark zuckerberg have
political ambitions to change society
as well as
to make money what do you think
i think mark zuckerberg wants every
human
on earth who has an internet connection
to be a facebook user and i really mean
that i think he really believes that
his
his
ability to be a historic figure is to
connect the whole world
um we've heard that mantra so many times
connect the world connect the world what
he doesn't do is say what happens next
when the world is connected and that's
really one of the reasons why we wrote
the book is we've seen all the
consequences of that um i i you know i
think the future of facebook is uh the
trajectory doesn't look like it's going
to change at all especially with
the leadership in structured as the way
it is there's no oversight of mark
zuckerberg by the board of directors
there is ins internally he has more
power and more decision-making
um sort of authority than any than any
time really um so
so i don't expect things to really veer
into a different course
it may look different facebook the app
it may have different functions
but the core things about the technology
and the business i don't think will
change from what we're with with those
sort of things in place still
so this is an interesting question uh
about sheryl sandberg how much is sheryl
sandberg's lean in culture mantra
reflected in the facebook offices what's
it really like to be a woman at facebook
you know and that that's interesting
because obviously we still have this
kind of sense of silicon valley as very
male dominated a kind of broke
engineering driven culture
has that changed that facebook has
cheryl sandberg changed it
well i think when cheryl sandberg first
joined facebook there were some
certainly some changes made at the very
very beginning of her start at the
company we've heard from women who say
well you know finally there was a woman
you could come speak to finally there
was a woman at the top that you could at
least voice your issues with
um but it's interesting some of those
same women who were so thankful to have
her join said that upon reflection a
year or two later they were they were
incredibly disappointed um in how
little sort of fundamental change
happened at the top i mean this is a
company
where all the executives are still
overwhelmingly male
um
i think it was one point two years ago
they had more executives named chris
than they had women serving as
executives
um you know it's it's part of it is
engineering culture part of it is that
you know
when they look at who they hire they
they claim that it's higher harder to
hire women than it is to hire men
but you know fundamentally
facebook still has an issue
with with women and how women get
promoted within the company that many
women spoke to us for um
about for this book
so this is a kind of anonymous creed
occur
says
most people know that facebook is bad
but owing to its monopoly
and obviously that includes instagram
and whatsapp we feel trapped dependent
on it for communication
how can this cycle be broken
i mean it's so true right that many
people feel like they
have to use these apps i think anybody
who's part of a group a sports group or
a club a parent association
will you know oftentimes have to
subscribe to some sort of facebook group
because that's where people communicate
um
it has become absolutely utility for for
many people especially around the world
that outside the u.s
um i don't know if people are trapped i
think some people feel trapped i think a
lot of people feel very ambivalent about
their experience
they
know that they're uncomfortable with all
the news that they've heard over the
last several years and they have a sense
of some of the consequences and the
collateral damage that comes from the
company and its decisions but they also
feel like well this is actually the only
place where the majority of my friends
and family are
where my school actually issues
announcements for my children i mean
it's
it's at this point becomes such a
such a ubiquitous
tool that's being used for
communications beyond the phone i mean
it's just
i don't i think it's influenced as it's
just it's sort of unmistakable and it
can't really change
does that sound really dark yeah
i mean i i i would add that you know
it's not just facebook
i talk to plenty of people who say well
i'm not on facebook and then
my immediate next question is well are
you on instagram or are you on whatsapp
because those are those are the same
company it's
it's led by the same people i mean
misinformation is is growing on whatsapp
and and nobody really knows what to do
about it
i you know there are also countries all
over the world where government
institutions are issuing you know their
their ruling largely through facebook
you know if you want to know what your
local department of education is doing
you have to go to facebook to find out
so facebook's here it's to stay it's
it's so intermeshed in
really a really incredibly global way i
mean the question is really just how can
we how can we be more responsible
in our usage of it yeah i mean the
misinformation on whatsapp thing's
interesting isn't it because it's it's
private and it's encrypted so
you know who who could re you know
obviously facebook can see it
theoretically but
um
it's a difficult one that so we have a
question from karen wilson and goes back
to this idea of you know
hate and the proliferation of hate on
facebook and she says
you know is is mark zuckerberg able if
he wanted to tomorrow
could he stop the proliferation of hey i
mean i guess he couldn't stop everything
but could can he turn this switch off or
is it kind of almost beyond his control
at this point frankenstein's monster and
so what and so forth
um
there's no switch it's not ever that
easy um
could they do more yes there's always
more they can do they're a trillion
dollar company i think especially again
i hate to go back to this but in the
parts of the world where um facebook is
still being used in massive numbers
you know if you if you if facebook were
to ever issue a per capita breakdown of
how many moderators they had
working on the you know in portuguese
working in um in burmese you know
working in all these other places i'm
sure that the number would be really
frightening compared to what they have
in terms of english language content
moderation um so yes there's always more
that they can do and and really there's
um there's more governments can do as
well in terms of helping facebook figure
out what what what should be the role
here i mean should governments
have a role in saying to facebook right
we're drawing
our line is here if you have speech on
your platform that disenfranchises
people from voting
that's that that's not you know that's
not something we're going to allow um
you know if you have
content on your platform which in the
middle of pandemic causes people to
behave in a way that threatens public
health we're not going to allow that do
governments start to play that role
rather than waiting for facebook to
always be responsive
so one question i have is is
about you know you cover this in the
book about the cambridge analytica
scandal
um you know which is obviously a big
story in the uk
as well um
how
much of an inflection point was that how
big
was that internally how worried were
mark zuckerberg and senior facebook
leaders about
that scandal or
was it just another pr issue for them
you know it was a huge moment it was a
big turning point internally and also
among the public
um
this is mind you right after
there were discoveries of foreign
intellectual interference on the
platform so there was already a
suspicion around the company and also
anger towards the company um among users
lawmakers around the world so cambridge
analytica what that did was it actually
gave people a different view of facebook
and understanding how the machine works
a little bit more understanding how data
was had been transferred for many many
years between the company and third
parties thousands of third parties and
it just it was a wake-up call for for
users in that they realized wow
the amount of data i have is the amount
of data that facebook has on me is so
vast and so broad and not only that but
they've been giving it away to so many
other third parties they've been
essentially polluting the internet with
my own data i have lost control so it
was another it was almost just another
way of looking at facebook and
understanding and educating people about
how facebook operates as a technology
and as a business
it was a huge inflection point the
delete facebook sort of movement on on
twitter and other social media platforms
sort of came from that so and internally
they were absolutely afraid of the
fallout
and so we have a couple of questions
that are lumped together um both
anonymous one someone said what happened
to f8 fate the facebook dating service
which someone seemed quite disappointed
didn't take off and the other is what
happened to libra and their plan to
launch a facebook currency and i guess i
would i would lump those together and
say
are they still innovating at facebook
you know are they still coming up with
new ways you know i remember didn't they
buy some oculus rift a while back uh
yeah you know um vr you know virtual
reality and stuff are facebook still
you know how kind of
because you know a lot of what they seem
to do is buy up competition and you know
other people do the innovating on
facebook just
buys it all
which is what they did with whatsapp and
instagram but are they still internally
looking to sort of mold our future with
things like libra fates some of them
will obviously be rubbish others might
not you know what what's that kind of
forward thinking in that way
you know um
facebook would love to continue to buy
the competition i think many founders in
silicon valley are no longer interested
in selling to facebook um largely
because of the experience of companies
like instagram and whatsapp that were
promised certain things by mark
zuckerberg including autonomy and uh the
you know they were promised facebook was
going to maintain some of their values
around privacy and security and they
didn't see those things happen and now
you know you speak to founders who say
well i wouldn't sell to facebook because
i don't trust them to honor um some of
their agreements but you know now
facebook is much more in the business of
really trying to copy um or mimic
popular platforms out there we saw them
recently announce
um a plan to get newsletters started on
their platform i think it was
a few months ago now that they launched
reels which is meant to be sort of a
competitive tick tock neither one of
those appears to be very successful
they're still innovating they're still
trying to get ahead of competition or
imitate popular features of other of
their competition but i do think that
you know at least look at tick tock
right now it's it's really um it's
growth is immense it's tremendous it's
really threatening to encroach on some
of facebook's sort of core user base
um i think mark zuckerberg is very very
very worried that all of the public
backlash against facebook as a company
and this idea among young people that
it's just not cool anymore to be on
facebook is is going to ultimately hurt
them
so so we think tick tock is keeping mark
zuckerberg up and i or perhaps intruding
on his sort of yogic meditation or
whatever
anything that's hot keeps him up at
night yes
well because he was once he was once the
kid he was once the hot you know you
know the hot product on the market it
was his and i i'm sure that's um that's
difficult if that's no longer the case
yeah so we have a question
um
you know is it true that kamala harris
the vice president is soft on big tech
because the tech giants are based in her
state i would extend that and say there
have been accusations particularly from
the left in america and and the right
actually
that
the by administration is staffed with
lots of silicon valley types that they
are
you know in the same way that the obama
administration was very close to silicon
valley that that that has been echoed
in the biden administration uh are they
are they somewhat compromised you know
for all that they you know cecilia point
out they appointed people like tim wu
right right row regulation but actually
we also see a hell of a lot of alumnus
uh staffing across washington this is
obviously your bread and butter so yeah
so what do you think
yeah i mean i think the obama
administration the revolving door during
the administration was much much bigger
and much much more active but you're
absolutely right josh there are a lot of
people who
have come from tech who are in the
administration that um
it's very interesting that people who
have been
names
floated for very important roles um in
antitrust for example um at the
department of justice who have
backgrounds working for tech or their
firms even working for their law firms
working for techs their their
nominations have been slowed down they
have not been named because so many
public interest groups so much so much
of the public is so upset with the idea
that tech is influencing from within
trying to go into the administration and
influence from within so i think that
what's changed is accountability about
that people just don't think that that's
okay it's such a such a common practice
in washington and i think folks in
washington are a little bit jaded about
the revolving door i think outside of
washington
most people i speak to are sort of
astonished to hear that people recycle
in and out of government in the private
sector and i think at in this instance
there's just
a new stance a lot of people are saying
no that's not okay and so that's holding
up actually nominees
well that is probably quite encouraging
in a way because you know it used to be
goldman sachs and and and
and the big banks and there's obviously
still some of that too but it is silicon
valley is the kind of new the new
hotness so to speak but there's a
question from alex b
uh who says what role is sheryl sandberg
playing now if she's been diminished and
i would add to that could you see sheryl
sandberg leaving facebook given the kind
of status quo that you described that
she's she's no longer the sort of
very prominent established number two to
zuckerberg's number one so what what is
she doing and could she end up
finding something else to do
yes i mean over the years there's been a
lot of chatter about cheryl sandberg
leaving facebook as we write at one
point in our book she was looking at a
job in the clinton administration had
hillary clinton won we would have likely
seen her in the treasury department um
you know i think
cheryl sandberg isn't tied to facebook
the way that mark zuckerberg is she has
had a persona and a career outside of it
with her book lean in and option b
and i imagine that she wants something
else because at facebook she'll always
be a number two um position but you know
we also know that she's someone that
isn't gonna leave on a low note she
wants to kind of you know recap some of
her reputations she wants to to you know
to not be blamed for all the feelings
and faults of facebook and so
i'm not sure i think it's a it's a
question of um when she leaves and not
if she leaves um and in terms of what
she's doing now you know she's taken on
this interesting portfolio of doing um
sort of outreach to small businesses um
we've seen her really promoting this
idea that facebook is going to be doing
more with small businesses it uh
especially during the pandemic that was
something that she she talked about a
lot it was very interesting to me though
to notice that while she was doing this
you know she was in a sense left out of
the bigger discussions about the
pandemic you had mark zuckerberg being
the one to appear in in an interview um
dr fauci you had mark zuckerberg being
the one to talk to the head of you know
various kind of world health
organizations and play that much more
you know high profile and diplomatic
role
so just a couple more things then we've
got why does facebook get so much
backlash for outrage but twitter and
youtube don't i mean obviously they do
sometimes but do you think facebook gets
un
disproportionate amount of backlash
i say fair on youtube and i'll come back
to that i would remind folks on twitter
that twitter is actually much smaller
than facebook much much smaller though
it does amplify
messages in a way that's so powerful
especially the former president
president trump and that information
gets
hops onto other platforms and makes it
into the mainstream mainstream
um look twitter is um has been
more proactive when it comes to
political figures and they've been
willing to experiment as well and
they're very transparent on how they're
coming up with the speech policy they
also say very just just very openly like
look we're trying to figure it out
please academics come in we want to
share all of our data with you and what
we know come in and help us academics
the public et cetera
so twitter has definitely not made all
the right decisions it's made tons of
mistakes in the long run but they've
been willing to be a little bit more um
aggressive so
i think that in that way there's a lot
of anger towards twitter but people
can see that they're trying to
to to change things
youtube is really fascinating case study
it has kind of been a sleeper people do
not pay attention to how
how youtube is such an important source
of information and misinformation
and shira's report on this quite a bit
there is just so much dangerous
information that gets caught that gets
um sort of passed along and passed along
and not and also through the recommend
recommendation engines just keep being
amplified i think youtube has taken some
efforts especially on the recommendation
engine to try to suppress some of that
and slow down some of that but
i we actually kind of laugh within the
tech team at the new york times that we
don't laugh but we we always do kind of
scratch our heads like it's so
interesting that people don't focus on
as much on youtube we're very interested
in focusing on youtube that i should say
uh as a reporter who covers
misinformation i'm always kicking myself
for not doing more youtube stories that
they are more difficult to do because
youtube is constantly removing videos
and then not explaining why or making it
impossible to even find out when they've
removed the video or or why
um but i absolutely think it's going to
be something a lot more reporters start
to look at and and try to sort of unlock
is this idea of how misinformation and
how hateful speech is being spread on
youtube
so we have our last question and it's a
we're going to do it as an exit question
yes or no
from both of you do you think mark
zuckerberg will ever be satisfied with
the amount of power he has
oh i'm going to cop out
and say um
i don't know it depends on how much
power he gets
fair enough
oh you know i've uh it's an expression
um i first heard it in arabic i don't
know where it originated but it goes
you know
those in power begets a thirst for more
power it's probably the best translation
um i've certainly seen it in powerful
people that i've encountered in my life
that
once they have some power they tend to
have a thirst for much more
um
so i imagine if mark follows that
pattern he will continue to want to be
increasingly powerful i don't know where
you go from here in terms of power
um
but i i i imagine much like bill gates
when he left mike you know he became the
head of the um sorry he became ahead of
the bill and melinda gates foundation i
can see mark
doing something like that and becoming
powerful in a different way
brilliant well that just about ties it
up i just want to remind everyone you
can buy a discounted copy of shira and
cecelia's excellent book and it is
excellent i say that i have actually
read it covered the cover at this point
um an ugly truth inside facebook's
battle for domination
um
so yeah you have the link for that and
thank you for joining us thank you
cecilia and shira for
lovely answers uh very insightful and
entertaining which is you know the
combination we want so
great to do great to see you both and uh
thank you everyone for watching thank
you for your questions